President Trump saying he never directed
his former personal attorney Michael
Cohen to break the law the exclusive Fox
News interview in just a moment but
first in the wake of all the Muller
probe developments Democrats continue to
beat the impeachment drum and predict
the president's demise I believe that
this president is dangerous I think he
has undermined our democracy
I think he's aligned himself with the
enemy with Putin he loves dictators and
I believe that he certainly qualifies
for impeachment we may never get it done
and maybe Democrats fear that somehow if
we move to impeach him maybe his base
will grow larger I don't think so I'm
prepared to say something I've never
said the writing's on the wall the walls
are closing in and this is the beginning
of the end for the Trump administration
this comes as Trump defends himself
against accusations of any wrongdoing
with Michael Cohen I never directed him
to do anything incorrect or wrong and he
understands that look he did some bad
things unrelated to me maybe related to
his other clients I wasn't his only
client number one they say it's not a
campaign finance violation number two or
it's not even under campaign finance
number two if it was it's not even a
violation number three it's a civil
matter you know President Obama had a
really big one from ten times more money
much more money and you know what he
paid a fine I'm the only one that this
happens to so what happened is either
Cohn or the prosecutors in order to
embarrass me said listen I'm making this
deal for reduced time and everything
else do me a favor put these two charges
on then that criminal all right so we're
gonna take it around the table the thing
is and let's start with you
so democratic political elites those are
the establishment they know the
political perils of going for
impeachment but the base they really
want President Trump to be impeached so
they're kind of in between a rock and a
hard place
that's true I also think that what I
don't understand is how you can
reconcile that and I there's just a few
things about impeachment that I feel
like should be part of the conversation
so one of them being the amount of time
and effort and cost that it takes to
what end
we all know that there would be an
acquittal in the Senate and secondly the
call today from representative ship
about oh we should amend or make an
exception to the office of legal
counsels decision
I read that decision and that affirms a
1973 decision and that calls up and that
calls up - literally going back to the
Federalist Papers and including
equipment alone and the N Clinton V
Jones and so to me the greater travesty
is that we are having legislators call
for that kind of influence on the DOJ
when isn't the entire conversation this
whole time and all of their shouting
about separation of powers so that level
of influence to me and that kind of
Vendetta and we seen my taxpayer dollars
for that reason that's what's
unacceptable I like the hand gestures go
ahead bring bring it bring more of it on
what do you think is gonna happen when
this between us push and pull I mean
it's it's like the the base is pushing
forward they want this impeachment and
you've got people like Nancy Pelosi like
let's just tap the brakes on that but
can she withhold those forces oh yeah I
mean I don't I don't I just don't think
this is that very realistic at this
point people like Steny Hoyer who's the
number to say listen just wait on mower
let's see what he has let's see what
comes but if you're talking about the
American people a lot of American people
think that what's been going on is
pretty outrageous and they worry about
it not only in terms of what one
congressman a heck of Washington we saw
him in the at the start of the show said
there been 36 36 people have been
indicted three people now prison terms
is that you start to think what is going
on with the president United States why
is he so friendly with Putin you know is
this a distraction even for Republicans
Dana I think you see Republicans
starting to say hey I don't know about
that I don't know about the wall etc but
I think the key today was how President
Trump is just so so wily trying to
distance himself from people who get in
trouble specifically Michael Cawley says
oh remember a long time ago he said I
didn't know anything about these
payments no payment was made then we had
Giuliani said yes the payment was made
and Trump repaid Cohen and now he's now
you heard Trump saying oh you noticed a
low-level employee I don't even think he
was a lawyer I think he was a PR guy you
say a PR people are really important by
the way
yeah but-but-but a day ago he sent me a
lawyer should know and he's described
Cohen as a lawyer who would should know
if he was making legal payment as a PR
guy but Jesse let's take a look real
quick at something else it happened
during the interview today I think you
might be interested in this building
that the president said we have that I
just need this on the front page of The
Wall Street Journal which just came out
look Trump didn't violate campaign
finance laws and neither did the
president Trump X a so they're saying
wait I interviewed him on my program the
other bonds yes Michael code pled guilty
to something that's not even a crime you
know that guy Hans von Spakovsky hv h hv
yes i have the sheet right here i'm
bringing it to every single v until this
thing is concluded I'm gonna make one
read it one this is your homework take
off my hands thank you I'm gonna test
you tomorrow on it I review all right so
yes obviously the FEC I'm not even a
bore you with it because it's very
granular a lot of people that know a lot
about the campaign finance law do not
believe this payment violated any law
whatsoever what about the prosecutors
which prosecutors oh I think the New
York Southern District of New York
apparently think there's some other part
isn't prosecute all their parties at
length the president with the other
crimes that Cohen committed regarding
taxes and that was the most of the
sentence the the harassment thing I
think the Democrats are playing with
fire and here's why do you remember what
happened with Cavanaugh so there was so
much injustice with Cavanaugh and so
much unfairness and it was so out of
bounds it really activated the
Republican base and if the Republicans
going into 2020 see partisan prosecutors
and maxeen and enter inter bandits going
after this president and a lot of kind
of shadowy people within the government
trying to take away a democratically
elected president from our republic
people are going to feel robbed and if
people feel like their votes are being
robbed they're gonna turn out so heavily
and there's going to be so much backlash
against this president it's going to be
astronomical another form of harassment
now Letitia James I believe like she's
the local AG here in New York City State
yeah state of them she just elected
she's
I'm going to investigate Trump Tower
Amin to investigate the Trump company I
may investigate the Trump foundation
there's a what crime is she
investigating she's just investigating
everything that says TR UMP regardless
of whether there's a crime that's not
how prosecutors that's not how attorney
generals are supposed to operate that's
outside the law all right Gregg we
covered a lot of ground so far but we
got to get your take yeah first of all
wan is not correct America doesn't care
about what's going on in this collusion
when it's pulled always pulls the lowest
in terms of concern America doesn't care
about people like Cohen these people
just happen to be on the periphery what
they care about is the economy jobs
their family which means national
security safety and law enforcement how
to protect this country they don't care
about this stuff the same way they
didn't care when they went after Bill
Clinton and what did the impeachment
proceedings do to Bill Clinton it made
America love him more because America
loves a bad boy you treat Trump faces if
Trump faces impeachment he becomes a
fonzie he will become Orange Fonzie I
have a compromise though for the people
who want impeachment uh just make ask
Trump to work half as much okay because
you want him gone because he just works
too hard so why does he just work half
as much because one Trump day is really
seven days in Democrat law and Democrat
days so why and so that is why the media
and why the Democrats look so exhausted
is because he's working them into the
ground so the compromise is just ask
Donald Trump don't work so much well I
can't so hard yeah he's taking a 16 day
Christmas holiday good for him and he
would he does five things in a day when
presidents usually get around a one but
they can't here's the thing impeach him
what do you get you get Pence Pence is
so conservative he once paid off a woman
after he shook her hand so you're gonna
trade in mr. right you're gonna get
mister even more right but anyway it's
just stupid this is such a travesty we'd
spend it so much time on this stupid
story okay well that was my block
[Laughter]